I had a difficult childhood and
you always have to be the best or
you always had to point yourself out now there are
also a few people I no longer
knew you have to accept but
don't have to listen to anything you
said correctly gelsenkirchen that's where
I was born  grew up and clicked football for the first time
my girlfriend yes it was
a lot of fun for
me to play these cages because the
conditions were not so good but it was
still a lot of fun
waiting there it was just so that the
place wasn't overrun white there were a lot of
stones
Although there is cinder space and you
have to be able to handle the ball very well at a young age
and
you started to play football at the age of 78
and yes, your parents are a brother or
cousin or some of them are against it and
friends know that well, so
they already know  twelve German man and of
course the
sister to pull through physical, it was just so that she
also from time to time n  Of course we got down to business
and then I had to
assert myself when I was young, as I said, with
my not so robust body
and that
definitely helped me a lot in the
premier league is the strongest league in the
world of course that’s how it is  first of
all a new environment the league is so tiring you don't have a
winter break and i play are also
very tiring you have to get
along with it as a newcomer i would say and of
course you have your difficulties
at the beginning of march but i was relatively clear
in this league you can  just having fun
i believe you the other leagues and
you can definitely
develop
and i just enjoy that i
can play for asia
i am also proud that i
can wear these wars now finally when you
have been in the top for so many years  leagues
continue to be contested, above all
physically, you also have to work very
hard on your body
knowing your body and getting a lot of sleep of
course and that’s exactly how
nutrition is very important and
you have to take these things into account and
do everything you can to make sure you’re just like
that i’m not the youngest
i’d say 30 years old anymore and that’s why i keep
so many  play for as long as possible
and that's why you have to take care of your
body you had a difficult
childhood and you
always had to be the best or
you always had to prove yourself more and that
just made me a lot stronger when I was younger
and now  there are also
some people who no longer accept me
but don't have to listen to
me there are always people who don't like me anymore there are also people who
stand next to me and the most important
thing now is to have fun with what you
have to do as a small child  i
lived soccer i still love it to this day
thats what i enjoy the most
and if you have fun and believe you
there are always people there  outside i want
to influence them they don't
want you to be successful and
just ignore them step on the gas believe in yourself have
fun and even if we achieve it at the end of the
day small goals i think
sometimes there are days where you
stop very early  trained it's also
cold and you've been in a bad mood so far
but as soon as i hold the ball very it's so
that you can kick it again it's
happy how happy is
easy again
there was nothing greater in football
i'm very proud of
some  is in my career won
both with bremen real madrid and asia
which i'm proud of which i'm proud
we just didn't take away
like i said when you look back like that so
great we'll score a goal home
in riga how much more successful
i hope i'll be  a few years before
me and of course hope that some
children will come
[music]